- Hi, everyone.
I'm Maurice Samuels,
the Director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Anti-Semitism.
And I wanna welcome you
to this special webinar
entitled, "Anti-Semitism After October 7".
I know that while the
war is still going on,
it's hard to think about anything,
except anxiety and grief.
But we nevertheless need
to begin to take stock
of the way that the
massacre of October 7th
has profoundly changed the
way Jews view the world
and the way the world views Jews.
To help us sort through
this complex situation,
I've invited Kenneth Stern
to speak with us today.
He's an author and attorney,
and serves as the Director
of the Bard Center for the Study of Hate.
Previously, he was Director
of the Division on
Anti-Semitism and Extremism
at the American Jewish Committee,
where he worked for 25 years.
Mr. Stern's op-eds and book reviews
have appeared in "The New York Times",
"The Washington Post", "The Forward",
and the "Jewish Telegraphic
Agency", and other places too.
His newest book, the
"Conflict Over the Conflict:
the Israel/Palestine Campus
Debate" was published in 2020.
I'm very grateful to Ken
for agreeing to join us
on very little notice today.
I can think of few people better qualified
to discuss the issue of anti-Semitism.
So here's how the webinar will work.
I will engage Ken in discussion
for about 30 minutes.
Then we'll take 30 minutes of
questions from the audience.
And we will end right around 6:00 PM.
So please submit questions at any time
during the discussion
using the Q&A function
at the bottom of your screen.
And I will relay the questions
during the question period.
The chat function has been disabled.
And I should say that American
Sign Language interpretation
is being provided live and can be accessed
by pinning the ASL interpreters.
So I realize this topic has
aroused a lot of passion,
but I want to discuss it today in as calm
and rational a manner as possible.
And I urge you to write
questions in that spirit.
And I urge you to keep
the questions focused
on the issue of anti-Semitism.
You know, there are many other topics,
like the how Israel
should conduct the war,
things like that that we
really can't get to today.
So with that said, let's
start on the discussion.
There's a lot to get to.
So hi, Ken.
- Maurice, thank you.
- Thank you, thank you for inviting me,
and thank you for giving the opportunity
to talk with your audience.
As you know, I'm a fan of your work.
And I'm just honored to be able
to have this discussion with you tonight.
- Oh, well, thank you so much.
And welcome to everybody here.
So let's get started.
So right after October 7th,
as the horror of the massacre emerged,
there was an outpouring of revulsion
against Hamas and sympathy for Israel.
Then things began to change
when Israel's bombing of Gaza started.
Since then, we've seen some
really scary Anti-Semitic
incidents around the world,
including just in the
last few days, things...
It seems like things have been
getting dramatically worse.
The attack on the airport in Dagestan
was particularly scary.
And in the US, things
have gotten very scary.
The Anti-Defamation League
last week reported a 388%
increase in anti-Semitic
attack since October 7th,
compared with a year earlier.
So can you start by just saying
what you think is going on?
How worried should we be?
Is this a blip or a sea change?
And maybe another way of saying that is,
don't we always see a spike
in violence against Jews
after conflicts of the Middle East,
and then things settle down?
But maybe not.
I don't know, how do you see things?
- Well, it's very hard
to predict the future.
So we're at a moment now in the middle
of things being totally shaken up.
But you're right, if
you look historically,
there was a concern in
the '73 Yum Kippur War
where there was the Arab oil embargo.
And those of us who were
old enough to remember,
you know, we had to go
on even days and odd days
to fill up our tanks.
And it was a concern that
Jews were gonna be blamed,
and they really weren't.
There was the attacks that happened really
after the beginning of the second
(audio skips)
after the peace process
collapsed, and there was a spike.
To me, it was very reminiscent
of what we're seeing,
maybe on a somewhat smaller scale.
But it was...
I remember the places in the United States
and North America having some synagogues
that were being attacked,
much more so in Europe.
And then, what happened was in the US
after a few weeks after
the shooting stopped,
it dissipated not so much
in Europe a little bit,
but it still was at a level
a lot higher than before.
What may be different now
is that we're at a point
where the end of what's
happening is not clear.
And so, the continuing seeing
of pictures of civilians,
and Gaza being pulled outta rubble,
and babies in hospitals, and so forth,
I think are gonna contribute to some
of the continued attention to this.
And on campuses where
we've seen issues before,
the couple of the pro...
I think it was 2000 and...
It's either 2000...
I have the note down here, 2014.
Yeah, the attack, the war with Gaza,
Israel was in July.
Campus was out.
And in 2008, it was
January, so campus was out.
So that's one of the other
different factors here
now is students are very much on campus
and organizing around this.
- So on that question,
I know a lot of people are just shocked
by what's going on on college campuses.
How do you see it?
Are campuses hotbeds of anti-Semitism?
Is it only at certain campuses?
It seems like the Ivy League campuses
are getting the most attention, but...
And certainly what happened at Cornell
this week with those horrifying threats,
you know, from a another student.
So how do you understand what's happening
on college campuses?
- Well, you're right.
I mean, some of the incidents we've seen
have been particularly disgusting,
the Cornell one in particular.
But there have been others too,
threats of violence and so forth.
But in some ways, this isn't new.
I mean, you mentioned that I wrote a book
on the conflict over the conflict in 2020.
And there was already, again,
not on every college of 4,000 colleges.
Israel is not a big issue on most of them.
But on some of them, it is.
And on those campuses,
what's been transpiring
for a number of years is
this sort of binary view,
where people get into
their buckets of thinking,
"Ah, this only justice
on the Palestinian side.
There's no justice on the
Israeli side," or vice versa,
and trying to suppress
speech on each side.
So we've had over the years,
although not as ubiquitous
as some people would portray,
incidents where Israeli
or or pro-Israel speakers
were shouted down, a heckler's veto.
We've had attempts to...
You know, professors who have decided
that their politics are more important
to them than the responsibility
to their students,
so I'm not gonna write a
letter of recommendation
for somebody to go study in Israel.
You've had a push from time to time
to have academic boycotts of Israel
because people were so
upset with the variety
of things that Israel
stands for or has done.
Not recognizing that
in an academic setting,
the purpose of it is to look at ideas.
And when you segregate a
nationality, that's an abrogation.
So we've had that on one side.
We've also had actually last
year more of an escalation too,
where you've had at Berkeley, Vermont,
and New Paltz some decisions
to exclude Zionists
from spaces, like climate change,
or sexual survivor spaces,
which tells me that it's
sort of McCarthyism.
It's they have a right to
define their political groups.
But when you say a Zionist
shouldn't be in this space,
it's the same as saying
the '50s Communists
can't be in the space,
even though it has nothing to
do with this, the politics.
On the flip side of this binary,
which I think is very
caustic to the campus,
you've had attempts by the
organized Jewish community
to suppress some pro-Palestinian speech.
And there's a whole long
history of trying to use the,
what's called the IHRA
definition of anti-Semitism,
which I was the lead drafter
of in its early text and
its earlier iteration,
and trying to use it as a speech code
to stop certain speech on campus.
And we just had...
I think most people on
this call would find,
the Students for Justice in Palestine
statements over the last couple weeks
were reprehensible or worse.
But you had Jonathan Greenblatt going
and Ken Marcus telling universities
to go investigate your DeSantis
kicking off SJP groups.
That's also a violation
of academic freedom.
So you've had this sort
of divide beforehand,
but it's become on
steroids now on the campus.
- And that certainly was
the case with the reaction
to the Harvard students
who came out right,
pretty soon after October
7th with a statement
blaming Israel for the attacks.
And then, there was really
a backlash against them
and attempts to make
their identities known,
so people don't hire them.
What would you...
Do you think that was an overreaction
on the part of the Jewish community there,
or Jewish donors to the Harvard students?
And if so, what would've
been a better response?
- Yeah, I think it was pretty awful.
I mean, these are 18, 19 and 20-year-olds.
And you're going after them
and saying they shouldn't be employed.
They should have a mark against 'em.
It's a blacklist.
I mean, the reason why I'm against
the academic boycott is also
because it's a blacklist.
And I don't think I
blacklist with blacklists,
the doxxing and the
inherent threat of violence
that comes with we know where you live
and we're gonna put a truck
in front of your house,
you know, to me is disgusting,
but that's not new.
I mean, there's a thing
called Canary Mission,
which has been around and
has identified students
that the Canary Mission
folks have objection
to some of their speech.
And I share a lot of their objections.
But when you create a list
that sort of marks them,
that's something-
- So what's a better...
- What should we do then?
Yeah.
- Yeah, so I think you
speak out against it.
I think you encourage others to
speak out against that type of speech.
You don't try to penalize it
because it is free speech.
But you use on an academy,
you use the tools you have at hand, right?
You use the educational process
to mine in a very difficult moment.
And there are things that
you can do short-term
and things that you can do long-term.
Short-term, I know a colleague of of ours,
Susanna Heschel and a few others,
immediately did a very
good program at Dartmouth.
There have been places,
Bard and other places too,
that have done vigils.
I think Williams as well.
And at Bard last Thursday,
I mean, Bard has had a lot of programs.
One that we put together
was looking at the issue
of laws of war and
Islamophobia and anti-Semitism
in the aftermath of this.
And I had a subtext for that.
It was very crowded.
It was intense discussion,
but I wanted students
to get out of their binary boxes
and not to feed the binary.
So the binary boxes, again,
are Israel is 100% responsible.
This is all about the occupation.
It's all about settler colonialism.
And then, the other side is the,
wait a minute, this is...
How could you not condemn baby
killing and some of the...
I don't know if you saw
the Blinken's testimony
about some of the more
gruesome things that happened,
you know, and not condemned that.
So what I wanted the
students to realize was that,
A, 'cause we run a center
for hate that it's not
the first time hate has
gotten to this point,
where their bombs are happening,
and people are getting
shot, and atrocities.
And there's actually
a rule of how you deal
with these things, and
it's the rules of war.
So I wanted them to see that
and where both sides may not be...
You know, or certainly not...
Well, one, either Hamas
clearly and Israel,
you can point to certain questions
about whether they're living
up to the laws of war.
And then on the anti-Semitism
and Islamophobia,
I wanted them to understand
precisely how hatred works.
You know, when I have
discussions about this topic,
and actually a lot of
discussions around the book,
I go back to the, the first chapter,
which is about how when our identity
is tethered to an issue of
social justice or injustice,
our brains actually function differently.
There's brain science that show shows.
That there's social psychology.
There are other fields that show
our brains fire differently,
that we try to reduce
things to simplicity,
and all right, and all wrong.
We're allergic to complexity.
And we just get further and
further into our own bubbles.
And when you sort of understand that
that's what happens when we feel this way,
I think it creates an intellectual space
to be able to engage with that more.
So that was one of the things
I shared with the students.
And also, about the uptick
in anti-Semitism and Islamophobia.
I mean, there have been
the murder of that,
you know, six-year-old child.
And I have a friend in the UK
who monitors online
anti-Semitism and Islamophobia,
both, of course, have spiked tremendously.
But they said this is the first time
you've seen them happen in tandem.
- Yeah.
- The point I wanted
students to come away with is
this is how hatred works.
This animates a certain number of people
to feel justified to act on
it with things of violence.
You may not act.
You're not gonna act it in a violent way.
But some of the things that stir them
are probably going on with you.
And I want 'em to be able to reflect.
So things like that.
And I could talk about more
things to do on campus.
- Yeah, so what about just
a kind of basic vexing
question in anti-Semitism studies is,
how do you distinguish between legitimate
criticism of Israel's
policies, even the war,
and anti-Semitism?
And where do we put that line?
And has...
This is obviously a question I know
you've thought a lot about.
But has the recent war changed
how you've thought about this question?
- It hasn't changed
how I thought about it.
I think...
And I wrote a piece for
an Israeli think tank
a couple of years ago about this.
That basically, anti-Semitism at its core
is two things, right?
It's conspiracy theory that believe Jews
are conspiring to harm humanity
and gives an explanation for
what goes wrong in the world,
from missing Christian children
back in the Blood Libel days
to Marjorie Taylor Greene and
Jewish space lasers, right?
So that's the core of
how anti-Semitism works.
So if one is cut and pasting Israel
and putting in that place, that's fine.
On the other side of the spectrum,
there are Palestinian
folks who are saying,
wait a minute, Zionism means
that basically Jews came
and disrupted our ability
to control our lives.
And that's why they are anti-Zionists.
They don't believe that there
should be a Jewish state.
Do they believe that Jews
should be slaughtered like this?
The ones that I conversed with, no.
They believe in a one state
with everybody getting a vote.
Now, that's a problem for...
I mean, certainly a problem
for Jews before October 7th,
when who's gonna trust that that's
gonna work out hunky dory?
But to me, you can make the argument
that it's functionally
anti-Semitic and anti-Palestinian
because it's gonna be perpetual warfare.
But does that mean that they're
motivated by hatred of Jews?
No.
And when I teach about this,
I use a essay by Derek Penslar of Harvard.
It's sort of a what if essay.
And he talks about, what if it had been,
instead of Jews coming back
to their historic homeland,
it had been a Protestant
group called the Templars
that had come and reconstituted?
There wouldn't have been more
like the reaction to Rhodesia.
So to me, there's clear instances
where anti-Zionism is anti-Semitism,
clear instances where
anti-Zionism is not anti-Semitism.
And there's a whole bunch
of gray in the middle,
depending on intent, and
context, and so forth.
- Yeah, so one of those instances...
So last week on the Yale campus,
there was a pro-Palestine
walkout, they called it.
I saw it.
And there were signs saying,
"From the river to the Sea,
Palestine will be free."
And many, including the
Anti-Defamation League,
considered this slogan anti-Semitic.
I think they see it as
a kind of dog whistle
implying the extermination of Jews,
or at least the erasure of Israel.
But other people don't
see that as anti-Semitic.
So that seems to be one
of the kind of gray areas.
How do you understand that
slogan as a concrete example?
- Yeah, I mean, precisely, it's ambiguous.
'Cause somebody could mean we just...
Yeah, from the river to the sea,
we're gonna wipe out all
the Jews and take it over.
And that's one way that
that could be interpreted.
It could also mean from
the river to the sea,
we're gonna have a democratic society
where this one person, one vote.
And so, the context of it is important.
You know, and I think one of the problems
with looking about
anti-Semitism is, again,
you know, we wanna get
into that comfort space
where we say, "Oh, it's
clearly anti-Semitic,"
or, "Ah, it's not antisemitic at all."
And there are a lot of things
that are much more ambiguous.
And I think to the extent that we say,
okay, how do we look at this problem,
rather than sticking
in one pin or another,
and then moving on,
I think the better we
we're able to understand
and what to do about it.
- Okay.
So I'm gonna shift a little bit to talk
about the American government's
reaction to October 7th.
And I think it was pretty striking that
the Biden administration has been,
you know, very strongly,
at least initially,
supportive of Israel in
the wake of the attack.
How do you understand that?
So this is now we're talking about maybe
the opposite of anti-Semitism here.
Is it...
And do you see it beginning to weaken now?
- Well, I was impressed where
the Biden administration,
some other foreign leaders too,
came out because they see a lot
of different interests involved.
One is just on the moral tone,
the slaughter and the brutality was,
you know, absolutely revolting.
And as a leader, I presume you'd think,
what would you do if that
happened to your people?
And what would the responsibilities be?
So the full throated support of Israel
to be able to deal with
this is not surprising.
Now, the devil is in the details, right?
So there's...
You know, I'm...
Again, you don't wanna go too far
into the conflict situation,
but I'm not convinced that
one can wipe out Hamas.
It's an idea and maybe there'd be
something worse that comes.
I'm not sure what the plans
are for the day after.
But I've also seen the
Biden administration,
you know, to my satisfaction at least,
publicly talking about there...
These are the lessons from Afghanistan.
This is what...
This is the rabbit hole
you may be going down.
You know, don't make the
same mistakes we did.
And then, also having
concerns for civilians.
And so, whether that's gonna change,
the bombing continues, I don't know.
I mean, it's certainly a
possibility that it may change.
And one of the calculations, again,
is that you've seen some,
you know, progressive
Democrats, who are...
You know, I fully
understand it, seeing the...
You know, when you see dead babies
and you don't think,
gee, this should stop.
There's a challenge there.
And some of those folks are saying
they're so upset with Biden for not
stopping Israel from this response,
that they're never gonna vote for him.
And so, is that gonna be
something that's gonna be...
You know, the support of Israel
if he loses the election?
Some are gonna have that narrative,
- Right, and is...
You know, I mean, it
just seems to me like,
okay, so that means that Trump
will be elected next time?
Is that gonna be great
for progressive causes?
That seems to be a really, you know...
I understand that perhaps they're,
you know, these progressive
groups feel like
they need to threaten
loss of support for Biden.
But I think that that just seems
like a completely irrational response.
But anyway, that's my own editorializing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So let's talk a little bit more
about Jewish groups who are anti-Zionist.
Or maybe not even anti-Zionists,
but really oppose this war
and are calling for a ceasefire.
How do you understand that?
Is that, you know...
Do you put that in the same category as,
you know, different forms of anti-Zionism
that do cross the line to anti-Semitism?
I guess another way of
saying that is, are there...
You know, do you see that...
Are Jews exempt from anti-Semitism?
Or how do you...
How do you understand that Jewish
anti-Zionist response?
- Yeah, Jews aren't
exempt from anti-Semitism.
Jews could be anti-Semitic, just like,
you know, Black people could
be racist, and so forth.
That being said, I see debate
inside the Jewish community.
And this is one of the
things that disturbs me
about some of the
pushing of the definition
for application on campuses saying,
to be Jewish means you have to have
an identity with Israel.
You have to be a Zionist.
I'm a Zionist.
Israel's a part of my Jewish identity.
But I realized that for some Jews,
that's not in fact the case.
And I interviewed a number of them
when I was putting together the book.
And again, I don't have data
for this particular thing,
but a lot of anecdotes.
And the anecdotes sorta
go something like this.
I went to Jewish day school.
A lot of the people in,
if not now in particular,
and also JVP, I think
some had Jewish education.
And some of them are children
and grandchildren of Jewish
communal staff and lay leaders.
Had a Jewish education.
I go to college.
And for the first time I hear
there's something called an occupation.
And I feel betrayed in what's going on.
And I learned about how
we treat the stranger.
I learned about repairing the world.
I can't justify the
existence of a Jewish state
on top of a Palestinian population
as something that
comports with my Judaism.
Now, I can argue with them.
I can disagree with them.
But who am I to say that
they're outside the tent
of what being Jewish should mean.
- Yeah.
Okay, and maybe one last
question that I'll ask you
before going to the
questions from the audience.
And I do urge you all to put
questions in the Q&A function.
So who has a right to
talk about these issues?
You know, I think that
a lot of Jews feel like,
you know, are suspicious when...
You know, they can certainly
understand why Palestinians,
maybe all Arabs, are concerned about this.
They can maybe understand why other Jews
are concerned about this on both sides.
But I think there's
sometimes some suspicion
why non-Jews are so energized
about this question.
And how do you see that?
Like, who has a right to
talk about these issues
on campuses or elsewhere?
- I think anybody has a right
to talk about these issues.
But the sort of...
If you look back at the
sort of timeline of where,
you know, there's sort of
been a left-wing critique
of Israel, it's an interesting timeline.
And it goes a lot with the politics
and progressive movement,
which I consider myself
part of, historically.
If you look back at
the National Lawyer's
Guild Resolution of 1948...
And the Lawyer's Guild is a
progressive organization that
has been very much in
the forefront of work,
opposing the Israeli government.
1948 resolution reads
like a Leon Uris novel.
It's like you support the Haganah.
The Arabs are attacking, why?
Because at that moment in time,
Israel was seen as socialist
and an anti-colonialist.
And the Russians were supportive.
And so, that was the political dynamic.
Then you have, I think
'67 was a watershed,
where a lot of progressives,
and non-aligned countries,
and so forth said, "What's going on here?"
And started to see this is a flip to
adopting the Palestinian narrative,
as opposed to the Israeli one.
Then you started seeing the left.
I mean, if you look at
the political statement
of the Weather Underground,
it reads like contemporary thing from SJP.
So it's been part of the...
I think, there were times where there
were certain movements that
people coalesced around,
South Africa, and anti-war, and so forth.
And this has the imagination,
partly because I think a
lot of people are concerned
because the Holy Land
is an important place.
It's a US ally.
It gets a lot of of money,
gets a lot of attention.
But it's also become one of those binary,
you know, good and bad symbols.
And again, when we're
talking about a campus,
the thing to me is to try
to break down that binary
to show it's more complicated.
So there have been some
efforts to do that.
But I'll give you one thing
that came up in my talk at Bard.
I mean, one of the simple or binary,
how do we look at this
and we don't have to think about it is
Israel's a settler colonial
state, end of the story, okay?
So it's the indigenous
people are being hurt.
And I have in my book, I have
the two competing narratives.
And they sort of fly
by each other at night.
But I had this couplet that I pointed
out to a student who's pushing this.
And I talked about the fact that
there was a group called ACBI,
the Palestinian Campaign for the Academic
and Cultural Boycott of Israel.
It sent a letter to the Iroquois
Confederacy in New York,
because the Iroquois folks have a...
Lacrosse is...
They claim to have invented it.
They're very much involved
in international lacrosse.
It was gonna be an international lacrosse
tournament in Tel Aviv.
And they said, "You're indigenous like us.
You're a victim of settler
colonialism like us.
It'll be a betrayal for
you to come, don't."
And then, I contrast it with an article,
short couple paragraphs from Judea Pearl,
you may know as, teachers at UCLA,
Or (speaks indistinctly)
his son, Daniel Pearl,
was the journalist who was beheaded.
And he said, "Name me another
settler colonial state
where you have people
speaking the language
that was spoken there
before the, you know,
so-called indigenous folks.
Name me another place
where people have been
talking about in their poetry, and lore,
and religion for thousands of years
of settler colonialists.
Name me another place
where you name cities,
New York, New Berlin, New Baghdad,
you know, not those things.
But names that they had
in times of the Bible."
And then I quote a historian who says,
"Real history is the ability to navigate
both those things simultaneously.
The rest is communal advocacy."
And the more I think we can underscore
that complexity to look
at and really understand
the narratives, that's a good thing.
I mean, one final point
too is I tell students,
and I've been speaking
on a lot of campuses
even before this.
You know, none of them are gonna solve
the Israeli-Palestinian conflict.
All of them have control over
how they treat their classmates.
It's fine if they have strong,
you know, political views on this.
And as part of being a good advocate,
don't they want to engage with people
that have a different point of view.
That you'll learn more from people
that have a different point of view
from people that agree with you.
And I tell 'em, I used to
be a criminal trial lawyer.
You know, if I didn't...
I was...
If I didn't think about
how the prosecution
would present its case,
and was just focusing
on what I wanted to say,
but not having the imagination
to think about how they
were gonna approach it,
I would've been committing malpractice.
So the more you make it
as an educational good
to have the emotional capacity
and the intellectual curiosity,
the better off I think things will be.
- Yeah, okay.
So we have a lot of questions.
And several of the questions
are grouped around this issue.
So someone says, "Yesterday,
Harvard and UPenn
announced the formation of advisory boards
to combat anti-Semitism.
Why isn't the battle against
anti-Semitism included,
or already included, as
part of existing DEI,"
so diversity, equity and
inclusion infrastructure.
So as everyone...
Maybe people who aren't
part of universities
don't know that there is...
You know, there is a whole DEI
infrastructure on every campus.
And Jews seem to be left out of that.
So why do we...
You know, why is that?
- It depends on where.
There's some places where
anti-Semitism is included.
And I've done some
training for some places,
and some places where it's not.
And there are places before this,
that have decided they really wanted
to wrestle with issues of anti-Semitism.
And Lila Corwin Berman
at Temple put together
a commission that really
looked at the issue.
And it really just isn't a question
of support for students,
which is important,
or to think about it for administrators,
but it's also to think
about it for curriculum.
I think there needs to be
more classes on anti-Semitism.
But there also needs
to be more classes on,
how do you have difficult discussions
on issues that cut you to the core,
about the importance of academic freedom
and free speech,
about I think part of
the challenge on campus,
and I think this is partly
some what goes under DEI.
And I'm, again, supportive of a lot of it.
But I see sometimes where the message is
students should not be disturbed by ideas.
If you're gonna be disturbed by ideas,
you know, oh my God,
we've gotta protect you.
You're fragile.
To me, nobody should be harassed.
Nobody should be discriminated against.
Nobody should be threatened.
Nobody should be bullied.
But if you're not getting disturbed
by ideas on a college campus, you know,
why are you spending all
that money to go there?
- Right, but do you think that, I mean,
several people have pointed out that Jews
don't seem to be treated
as a minority worthy of,
you know, diversity sensitivity on campus.
You know, is do you feel like that's true?
You know, and that
certain things that people
have pointed out that are...
You know, you would never hear about other
minority groups are kind of tolerated
when it comes to Jews on campuses?
- It depends on the campus
and it depends on the context.
So there are a lot of campuses,
(audio garbles)
Jews, a lot of campuses
that have a lot of Jews.
There is some tendency among
some folks on the left to,
again, to go into these binary
spaces where Jews are white,
Jews are privileged.
How can you have
discrimination against them?
And that's not new.
And that's hurtful when...
You know, 20, 30 years ago
when I was doing training,
I was saying, for a Jewish student
who hears that something
that happens to them
can't possibly be hurtful
because they're white,
that's doubly dismissive
because they think
that the people that ought
to know, understand, don't.
So that happens in some places.
But for the majority of
what I've been able to see,
again, I haven't done a
survey of all 4,000 campuses,
is that if there's something
that's clearly anti-Semitic,
you know, white supremacist,
you know, leafleting or
something, that'll be dealt.
When it comes to Israel,
it's much more complicated.
And it's, again, you have Jewish students
who are taking the position
that is anti-Zionist.
I mean, there's a whole kerfuffle
about that speech at the CUNY
graduate at the law school,
where somebody who's giving a
virulently anti-Israel speech.
And the Jewish Law Student
Group was supportive of it.
So you have a variety.
And you also have Palestinian students.
And when you have a pushback on something
that's not clearly anti-Semitic,
but may make Jewish students
who have an Israel identity is part of it,
then you do something to harm
the Palestinian students too.
So the better response is not just
to think about, how am I gonna
go flag that type of speech?
It's, how do I bring
people together to have,
you know, conversations?
How should I change the academy,
so that people know they're
not gonna be harassed,
but they are gonna be disturbed?
And then what are we gonna do
with that, being disturbed?
- And what about someone is asking
if you really do feel that there should be
an immediate ceasefire
in the war right now.
And then some people are saying that
that's anti-Semitic to say that.
How do you respon... (laughs)
How do you respond to that?
- God, I'm glad I don't
have to make those decisions
about what to do or what
not to do in this context.
You know, as a human
being, I'm concerned about,
you know, the civilians
that are dying in Gaza.
It's heartbreaking.
I think, Israel has a right to defend.
And, well, I was asking an ethicist,
who's a philosopher friend of mine.
You know, the beginning of this.
I said, to get out the hostages,
that's an obligation for any country.
But when you do that,
you are going to cause
a lot of civilian damages.
How do you weigh that?
And he said basically, heck, if I know.
There's a rule war.
So there's Israel went after commanders,
but a lot of collateral damage.
How many, you know?
So I don't know what to...
I don't think...
I think there are some that are, you know,
clearly don't want Israel
to do anything at all.
And to me, you know,
that may be an indication
of something that is problematic.
Because if the United States
were attacked from Canada,
and then say, "Oh, don't respond,"
that wouldn't be an appropriate response.
But to have concerns about human beings
and thinking about, you know,
other ways forward other than just
bombing the heck out of the place,
I think that's reasonable
and not anti-Semitic.
But again, it depends on the context
and what the motivations are.
- Okay, and there are
a few questions about,
you know, trying to understand
what is motivating some...
And this is a hard question,
but what's motivating a lot
of the anti-Israel sentiment right now?
Is it...
Do you think that it's, you know,
unleashing prejudice
that was already there?
And another way of
putting this is, you know,
what's motivating, for instance, you know,
I was reading an article yesterday
about anti-Semitism on
the Chinese internet.
You know, and so, is that purely sympathy
for Palestinians?
Or do you think that there are
other things going on here?
- I think there's probably not one simple,
you know, situation.
I think there are some that, you know,
glom onto the good and bad.
And Palestinians are oppressed
and Israelis are oppressors.
And they feel some sort
of comfort in that.
Some of them may be going after Israel
because it's a Jewish state.
That's certainly, I
suspect some aspect of it.
But I think some of it is, you know,
again, seeing the pictures,
having the concerns.
And it's a variety of things
that I think motivate people.
But as what concerns me is that as long
as this goes on, that's
going to be a challenge.
And, I have friends, non-Jewish,
who are sympathetic to Israel,
but also at aghast at what's going on,
and thinking about a
ceasefire, and all that.
And I dunno at what point do you create,
you know, some more
antipathy to Israel when,
if there are 10,000 dead babies, 20,000?
You know, at what point does that create,
you know, a tremendous...
Aside from the dead people,
does that create challenges for Israel?
I don't know, I'm glad I don't have
to make decisions about what to do.
- Yeah, so here's a question that I know
is on a lot of people's minds.
How do you think social media has impacted
the landscape of anti-Semitism,
especially maybe on college campuses?
- I think it gives an
opportunity for people to,
you know, put things that are hateful
very quickly out there.
But to me, there's a whole discussion
about hate and social media,
and whether things should be regulated
even before October 7th.
And to me, it's about the
ideas more than the medium.
I mean, people worried about hate
when the printing press was put together.
And one can make the
case of the most hateful,
you know, thing about
Jews was probably things,
some things in the New Testament, right?
So television, radio, Father Coughlan,
early internet sites.
So they're all different ways
and they all communicate in
ways a little differently.
So I think it's part of the puzzle.
It allows people to communicate
and build sense of community.
But I think it also gives an opportunity
that we haven't fully tapped yet.
It's one of the things in the center
that we're looking at is,
how do we use social media
more effectively against hate?
I mean, to me, I'm sort of aghast that,
you know, we see hate crimes,
and there's no real easy
mechanism for people to use,
you know, social media to
know what their resources are,
how to report a hate
crime, all those things.
So there are ways of
building up our capacity
to fight hate a lot
better using social media.
It's a double-edged sword.
And to give you one final example of that,
just so that people
understand the context.
I mean, back at the time of
the Oklahoma City bombing,
it was the early internet days.
And there were a bunch of us watching
the militia movement
with its anti-Semitism
and its hatred of federal officials
really start taking shape
from one group to two groups,
10 groups, and 20 groups
in a couple of months
all around the country,
more than that even.
And so, a bunch of us got together
and were watching what they were posting
on these early bulletin boards.
So it gave the haters an
opportunity to feel community,
to spread rumors, to organize in a way
that they hadn't had before.
But it gave us an opportunity to also get
a better sense of what they were doing,
which is why a bunch of us put a warning
of watch for April 19th,
the anniversary of Waco.
Something's likely to happen.
So most of these things
are double-edged swords.
- Yeah, that's a great point.
Yeah, how can we use social
media to solve the problem,
rather than just let it keep causing it?
So a question about statements.
You know, I think that after October 7th,
immediately there seemed to
be this war over statements.
And especially, I think
on university campuses,
you know, were university Presidents
quick to put out a statement.
Were the statements
sufficiently pro-Israel,
or were they too pro-Israel?
How do you explain just the passion
that the statement question aroused?
And do you think statements
are a good thing?
What's your statement on statements?
- Well, I think people
sort of see it as a symbol.
And they try almost
with Talmudic intensity,
try to dissect it and doesn't...
You know, is it sufficient?
Is it insufficient?
Does it cover what I care about?
Or does it go to the other side?
Is it all those things?
This a University of Chicago-based report
that came out in the '60s
called "The Calvin Report"
that basically said universities really
ought to avoid stepping into
making political statements.
And I think, basically, that's right.
I mean, I did two
statements when I was at HJC
that got over 400 college
Presidents to sign.
One was when we saw attacks
on the Hillel Building at Berkeley,
and Concordia was a riot in 2002
with Jehuda Reinharz,
who's in at Brandeis,
and the late Jim Friedman from Dartmouth,
and a bunch of others who
put together a statement
that talked about the college President's
responsibility to the campus,
to not allow harassment,
not allow intimidation,
to keep it open to ideas, and so forth.
And then in 2007, I
worked with Lee Bollinger
and about 400 other college Presidents,
including Harold Shapiro of Princeton,
it was when the University
and College Union in the UK
put out a statement advancing
an academic book out of Israel.
And so, we got about 400 some odds
to sign onto Lee's statement, which was,
if that union was intent on dividing
the academic world into
Israelis, who should be shunned,
and everybody else, count us as Israelis.
This is the same time
the ADL was floating,
gee, maybe we should boycott
British academic institutions,
which in my view was
ridiculous to change the debate
from should we have academic boycotts
to who should be boycott?
But the principle of
both of those statements
was looking at the campus
and academic freedom
and what the campus should be.
And "The Calvin Report"
says that that's fine.
So what I was advising
when this was happening is,
yeah, I think it's
important for Presidents
not to be seen as silent
and ignoring this.
I think it's perfectly appropriate to put
out something that says we
know our students are hurting.
I think, and to what are the resources?
I think it's important to
talk about what the campus
can do at this time,
this educational mission,
and how we should be treating each other.
But to make a statement
about, even though personally,
you know, I would've deplored, obviously,
what Hamas was doing,
as a President, I probably would not have.
And I think Maud Mandel at Williams
put out a really smart statement.
It was a statement about why she wasn't
putting out a statement.
But it was very clear
that she was focusing
on what the campus
should do as opposed to,
you know, don't expect
the President's Office
to be the State Department.
- Right, but I understand that.
And I am sort of against statements also.
I wish that they had never gone
down that road to begin with.
But I can also understand
the other point of view,
which is once universities
start putting out statements
when some groups are hurt,
why are Jews left out?
You know, why doesn't the massacre of Jews
merit a statement, or why?
You know, so I do
understand that side also.
- Right, but I understand that too.
And that's why I think it's probably
a better policy not to put it out.
But I don't remember anybody,
you know, getting up on campus and...
There may have been some students,
but I don't remember
people organizing saying,
you know, that George Floyd got it coming.
Or back in those apartheid
South Africa days,
somebody saying apartheid is a good thing,
- Right.
- On this issue, you have
a lot of divisiveness
on the campus.
And so, I don't see campuses
putting out positions on abortion.
I don't see campuses saying, you know,
leave aside the 501(c)(3) problems.
You know, you should be opposing Trump.
- Right, but I'm just
gonna push back on that
because I think you could say,
well, but isn't the
massacre of innocent people
in Israel like an inherent moral,
you know, catastrophe that needs
to be denounced at that time, isn't it?
And isn't it the responsibility
of the university
to take a clear moral stance
on something like that?
- The answer is I, as
an individual, would.
But as a university President,
I'd be very hesitant to.
I mean, they haven't put
out statements about,
you know, the earthquake in Turkey.
They haven't put out statements
about a lot of other things.
I don't remember about the Uyghurs.
You know, I mean, you could talk this...
This was an atrocity that
was just unfathomable.
And I think there are
opportunities on a campus
to educate about this.
And I am concerned about students
who are so in that tunnel,
that that can't even to tick a box,
say, "You know, killing babies
is not such a good thing.
But we still were supporting
for Palestinian rights."
- Right.
- All we're saying...
You know, I have have a colleague
who teaches at Rutgers who was telling me
that one of the pro-Hamas students
was a student who thought
Hamas was a person.
There's a lot of ignorance out there,
and not knowing about what the Hamas is,
and its original charter, and
how it treats gays and women.
And so, there's a lot of education there,
but there is some, again, it's to me,
I'm more interested in
what a college President
does to use the educational-
- Right, I was just say...
I agree that statements are
inherently reductionist.
You know, and it's kind
of contrary to the mission
of what the university is supposed to do,
which is to give deep
context and to teach.
So this leads to...
'Cause we're sort of running outta time,
it leads to some other questions.
People pushing back on
the call precisely for,
you know, the response to anti-Semitism
being more education.
How do you do that when
people seem so dug in on this
issue that they just don't wanna learn,
or they're just so
completely ignorant that
they're just not willing to learn
and are taking these knee-jerk
positions on either side.
How then does education become the answer
in a situation like that
that's so resistant to it?
- Yeah, it's a great question.
And I think part of, again,
what a university needs to do
is broader than just
looking at this question.
It's the culture of
being disturbed by ideas
of finding new classes.
Again, new classes on anti-Semitism,
new classes on hatred, and you know,
the why people hate and why
we get into these boxes,
more programs that bring in people
with different points of view to model
how you can disagree on
strongly divergent views,
classes on how to do that.
Those things I think over
time will set the tone.
And it comes from the
university leadership,
it comes from the faculty.
And the more we can
empower those voices...
Is it gonna be like a silver bullet?
No, but I think ultimately
that's the best tool
that a campus has.
And when it goes down
the other road of saying,
we find this speech so deplorable
that we're gonna censor it,
it just feeds into the binary,
which is the problem in the first place.
There's also an opportunity here that,
you know, campuses have a turnover
at least a quarter of
their students every year.
So are you gonna, with programs
now, change a lot of minds?
Probably not, although, I think some were
changing the program that I participated,
I'm sure programs in other places.
But you have next year and the year after.
And I think, it's more of an expectation
when students come in of,
how do you treat each other?
How do you understand?
Those things will help set
that up a little bit better.
- And okay, that leads
into another question
that someone had, which is,
how should university administrations
manage these protests,
anti-Israel protests,
to make sure that they don't become
opportunities for anti-Semitic expression?
- I think anti-Semitic
expressions are awful,
but they're 1st Amendment protected.
So you're not gonna...
You're gonna punish a
student who's gonna say...
You know, like in Cornell,
make true threats.
Be very clear on that.
But you also want to
encourage the student body
to realize that there are things
that are being said
that are really hurtful
or perceived as hurtful by people,
and to understand the
more of the context of it.
So if they're gonna take a position
that I, as a Zionist, feel,
accustom me to the quick.
They at least ought to
know how to deal with that.
And on the flip side, again,
is to have a perception that
when you hear something,
you're not fragile.
You're gonna figure
out how you're gonna...
I remember at Bard years ago,
I walked onto the campus
and there was a big free Palestine sign.
I had not seen that before.
And it sort of made me very uncomfortable.
And then, I thought about it.
And I thought, that's
somebody has an opinion
I strongly disagree with.
I understand it makes
me deeply uncomfortable.
But I would be more uncomfortable
if the administration said
they can't express themselves.
And again, finding opportunities.
There are ways.
I mean, there are small
groups to bring together,
which I've done of people that are
strongly opposed on this issue,
but want to have the conversation,
and with text study and so forth.
Does it necessarily change minds?
No, but it's a possibility.
I'll give you one other
example and this is,
I have a blueprint for this
at the end of the book.
It was a class I love that a woman
named Natasha Gill came up with.
It was a simulation course.
So half the course was students
basically being actors.
And the course was looking
at the Peel Commission of the '30s.
So for those who don't recall, the Brits,
when they had the mandates
sent Lord Peel to figure out,
what the heck are we gonna do with this?
And they talked to
everybody, Arabs and Jews,
and came up with a report of what to do.
So this is before the
Holocaust, before '48,
before '67, before contemporary times,
so the guts of the conflict.
And it was well structured.
She gave students roles opposite
that would be an easy one for her.
So she gave a Pakistani Muslim,
had to be eight weeks faithfully
representing David Ben-Gurion.
And when I talked to the student about it,
she said, "You know, as
strange as that was for me,
it was probably stranger
for my Israeli classmate,
who had to be the mufti.
And as much as a pain in the butt he was,
the Jabotinsky figure on my
side was worse to deal with,
so like a little bit of reality.
And what I'd loved about
it is Natasha told me that,
you know, students would come in and say,
"Gee, we can figure out how this conflict
should have been resolved 80 years ago."
And they come out of it saying,
"Now, we understand why it hasn't been
resolved in 80 years."
That's education.
And the more things we can
do like that, the better.
- Okay, well, we are out of time.
And there are just many,
many more questions here
that I am gonna ask my assistant, Anesa,
to at least take pictures
of and we can send you.
One thing before we go.
Someone ask for just the reference
to the Derek Penslar article.
- Sure, I'll give you my email.
So if you want that or anything else,
please feel free to email.
It's kstern, so K-S-T-E-R-N,
at bard, B-A-R-D, .edu.
- Okay, terrific, thank you.
And thank you to all the participants
for your great questions.
And I apologize not for
not being able to answer
or to ask all of them.
I urge everybody.
You're probably already
on our mailing list.
But if you're not,
please do sign up there.
We're gonna have more
events around this conflict,
but also other events that
had been already scheduled
on very interesting topics, including,
you know, right-wing anti-Semitism
and other things relating
to the Middle East too.
So thank you all for attending.
And a special thanks to Ken
Stern for these, you know,
very helpful and
interesting comments today.
You can't hear everyone clapping,
but I will clap for everyone else.
And let's hope that this and soon, yeah.
- Yeah, thank you, Maur.
Thank, everybody.
- Okay.
- Thanks, everyone, bye.